[موسيقى]
الصوره تتحدث هنا من خلف ليال كما ترين
مظاهر الاحتفال بدات بالفعل هذا الشارع في
نهايته حزب العداله وتنميه مقر حزب
العداله وتنميه في في اسطنبول وكما ترين
بالفعل الاحتفالات بدات على الرغم من ان
هذه عمليه الفرز الاوليه نتائج اوليه
تتحدث عن فوز الرئيس التركيه رجب طيب
اردوغان هذا مشهد معاكس تماما لما كنا
ننقله منذ ساعه من الان في حزب الشعب
الجمهوريه الذي كان يقيم عليه الصمت
والحزن والترقب لانه كان بدا ان يفقد
الامل في ان يفوز بهذه الانتخابات لكن
توجهنا
حيث هذا الشارع
العداله والتنميه والاحتفالات بدات بالفعل
حتى قبل ان اتعلن النتائج الرسميه لهذه
الجوله الثانيه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه
ضحى يعني كما هو واضح
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات